the head coach of the Minnesota Vikings
now in his seventh season as such Mike
Zimmer back in the Rich Eisen show hiya
coach Rich how you doing everybody got a
fine in your neck of the woods in your
world healthy yeah everybody's doing
well the quarantine here in Kentucky is
that way so you're zooming in from
Kentucky right now coach yep I'm in
Kentucky I'm sitting in my bedroom
overlooking this little lake that we
have okay
so instead of I don't mean to make a dad
joke to start but instead of zooming D
does your team call it zooming is that
what they do it
Microsoft team okay I'm sorry I should
know my partnership for the NFL I should
know that I might lose something out of
my my paycheck this week I should know
that but so what does this like though
doing this you mean you're sitting in
Kentucky trying to coach a football team
in the NFC North we're now in May what
what in the world is this like for you
yeah it's it's strange but it really has
been you know meetings have been good
I've been able to sit in with the
offense we staggered so the offense has
their meetings and the defense special
teams and then the defense and so I'm
able to sit in on only all the different
stages which would be harder to do if we
were all at the same time but it's been
good for me the meetings have gone well
I've been impressed with the way our
coaches set up the meetings and the
installations and things like that the
most disappointing thing is that you can
coach these guys on the playbook
but once you you can't get them on the
field and then show them exactly how to
do it you know you can tell them what to
do but you can't show them how to do it
so that's that's the next step whenever
we do were able to get back to the
facilities that were excited about I
mean are you using from your coaching
playbook what happened in 2011 again
it's somewhat similar to that I mean
obviously a pandemic is much more
serious than a labor dispute but it
sounds like some of the language I heard
during the lockout year okay yeah it
really is a little bit like that I'm one
of the only guys that remember it I
think but but yeah it's a little bit
like that but um you know now we have
we didn't have all the computers when
you're able to use the Microsoft teams
and the different virtual meetings that
we did back now that we we didn't able
to do back then so I can again just walk
me through I mean are you sitting there
and and going from one team room to
another team room I mean how do you as a
head coach you know keep your finger in
every single spot typically we meet
together as an offense first and talk
about the run game and then the
offensive line leaves and goes to
another room virtually I guess and then
you know then that we will sit in with
the skilled players and talk about the
past plays predominantly protections
things like that and then we have it
then we have a team meeting well the
whole entire team comes in we'll talk to
them about situational football today we
did a presentation I did presentation on
red zone and then and then the special
teams meets for thirty minutes and then
we'll have a defensive meeting where
we'll sometimes we have virtual
walkthrough sometimes we have you know
like today we did a protection tape on
how offenses block different protections
and things like that so where you will
get a lot of that stuff done which which
is good okay you know obviously we'll
have to hit it
few more times before game but but I
think that part has been good Mike
Zimmer here on the Rich Eisen show and
again you know I'm sure you're learning
more about public health than you ever
thought you'd have to learn as a head
coach or a coach in the in any sport let
alone the NFL here what what are you
hearing about your protocols once you
can get back into your facility here and
when do you think that happens you know
well you know I'm very fortunate that
our children when our trainer is is a
head of one of the committee's you know
they have several committees while
they're trying to figure out exactly the
process that we go through and the
different things that you have to do but
you know we're preparing like we're
going to
you know get ready to go for regular
training camp it may not happen that way
you know we'll just have to adapt to it
but we're preparing like it's going to
be a just a normal season now obviously
though I'm sure there will be other
protocols
you know you get tested for the code of
19 you know maybe on game day they you
know they're talking about a lot of
different things but but you know
getting your temperature check when you
walk into the building so there's a lot
of different things that they're talking
about but not really anything that is
been set in stone yet are you are you
just saying that you might be preparing
yourself to figure out your active
inactive list waiting for a point of
access blood test to return like is that
a possibility for you what are you
talking about yeah well I don't think it
would be a blood test I think it would
be more of those saliva tests from what
I understand but again you know they
they have to get these all these testing
procedures figured out and how to do it
you know I don't think anybody wants to
have the stick going up your nose so
they're working on all those all those
types of things in order to get that but
yeah there's a possibility you know if
somebody touched positive on the day of
the game that he's gonna have to go
quarantine for 14 days but we're all
hopeful right now that we get to get the
vaccine done get the tests all squared
away and we get back to work because you
know that's what we love to do and we'd
love to have fans back in there you know
our fans and Minnesota are outstanding
it it would be it would basically suck
to play with our fans but we'll do
whatever we have to do Mike Zimmer here
on the Rich Eisen show let's talk about
your draft
were you surprised Justin Jefferson was
available for you to snag their 22nd
overall yeah you know which I think
every coach and GM always says we were
surprised that he was there when they
picked him but we really were this time
you know we didn't think he would slide
down that far to listen we're very
fortunate we had you know we had a group
of guys but he was the guy that we
really wanted you know he's he's an
outstanding receiver he's great on the
contested catches he's able to run all
kinds of different routes
some positions and we felt like he was
really Pro ready as it came in there and
and then obviously you were somebody who
made a made a deal with San Francisco
sitting there he had the 25th overall
pick walk me through the decision to to
make that move is that something where
you just moving around the draft board
because you thought the guy that you
were gonna choose eventually at 31st
overall would still be there was Gladney
a guy you were going to take it 25 walk
me through that process yeah typically
typically rich what happens is
experiment robbers in skiing and George
Payton are the guys are making all the
calls throughout the throughout the
course of the draft and you know we got
to that point we're picking 25th there
was a there was an opportunity where
there was three or four guys there so we
we we felt like landing was going to be
there but if not we had a couple of
options that we would have what we would
have went to we are fortunate that he
fell down to us and you know sometimes
collecting more draft capital is is
probably more important if you got two
or three guys you know whether it be an
offensive lineman or at i-10 or whatever
position you got three or four guys
sitting there and you feel like you can
move back five or six spots you can you
can get some more grass capital which
can help us with ball team well I mean
if you just hear me out here coach
so by making that deal San Francisco
goes in grabs are you out of Arizona
State who again I'm sure I'm sure but
you but you also you know grabbed your
guy and Justin Jefferson before well the
reason why I bring all this up is that
might have been a guy that could have
been available for Green Bay for
instance just throwing that team out
there because they then traded up to go
get Jordan Love which I don't know if
you've noticed is create a bit of a stir
within your division do you think you
might have wound it up a little bit here
by making that trade deep down which I'm
I'm gonna go political onion I only care
come on because there seems to be a bit
of a hornet's nest that got kicked over
within your division coach what do you
think well yeah you know everybody's got
to do with this in his best interest
their organization committee Aaron
Rodgers is a great great player every
week preparing for him is extremely
difficult he's he's so good at
everything he does he's so smart he sees
blitzes and everything like that and
he's always you know he's a great player
so you know but they have to do what
they have to do and we have to do what
we have to do and um you know hopefully
it comes out comes out our way when we
can opening day well certainly if they
want to kick the tires on a young guy
and sit him right you'd be all for that
in Minnesota right yeah they could play
them if they want Jordan love you
talking about right now Aaron Rodgers
sure let's just figure out what and your
first time you take right let's just
figure out the first time it opens we
can wouldn't be a bad spot to in your
building right see what you oh man we're
just just lingering in a somewhat
serious way on this subject were you
surprised to see that pit as you were
going about your business for thirty
first overall you look up and you see
that the Packers chose a quarterback and
that's fun yeah I think yeah they moved
up to get him so I suppose that we were
surprised he's Jordan was a good player
we had high grades on him as well I did
you know I was talking ourselves you
know it took him quite honest you know
quite often and yes you know he said
well you know he said that that's really
not a bad idea to go out there and you
know get another young quarterback and
you know be prepared for if something
does happen or you know things like that
so you know there's there's a lot of
different ways to look at it you know
we're just more concerned about whoever
stopped in Aaron Rodgers I guess would
be the best way to say I best it
yes it would Mike Zimmer of the
Minnesota Vikings here on the Rich Eisen
shown again you are from the parcels
tree was the first time you met him was
the first time you met him coach when he
got hurt
actually there was a I was that was he
was back working out and I was in the
facility as of Saturday morning I
believe and he came in her I was working
out came back and on my debt on my desk
there was a note set see me BP so his
office was right next door about and so
that was really the first time I met him
I went in there we talked and you know I
said you know what do you want to know
about me and he said nothing I know
about I know all about you and this and
that and then I said well I'm specifical
duck hunting this weekend that Jerry
Jones's what do you you know what do you
want to do he said well he said you're
free to look around for another job and
and I said well one one you know and he
said in a couple weeks
probably and I said okay so I went down
duck hunting the next day I got a phone
call down at the duck hunting lodge and
it was him calling and he says to me you
you want this job here and I said yeah I
said why didn't you tell me yesterday I
just want to make sure you wanted it so
this was in Dallas when he was hired in
Dallas and you were a holdover right is
that what you're saying and he showed up
and right and kind of put you through a
test about wanting a job to stick with
him essentially right exactly well I
guess you passed the test huh we're
pretty good friends now you know we talk
every Monday morning when the phone
rings at 6:00 a.m. he calls and I know
it's him and we talk about the game and
he talks about you know things I could
have done better obviously are things I
did well you know and then we just
talked time to time I actually went down
to saw him last spring and went down in
Florida and we went to his Gulf country
club and we drew a bunch of things up on
that game so it was kind of fun but you
know he's a great mentor for me he's you
know he was hot he's hard on all of his
coaches but he
for some reason I guess he took a liking
to me well I mean you know everybody
that I've worked with that's played on a
team with you coaching on it says
nothing but the highest of regard for
you literally I mean like Deion Sanders
I know when he sat in for me he called
you up he had you on I mean
Deion thinks the absolute world of you
is he the biggest character you've ever
been on the same team with coach talk
about it let me call it so I put a bunch
of stories and I called me on and I put
him on speaker and he told the exact
same story exact same man who would
never talked it beyond and I would be
good friends and you know coming from
his background he had I left him to he's
just funny and he's he's a terrific
person yes so so your neighbors in
Kentucky are like hold on let me let me
just get Dianna on the phone to back up
what I'm saying and then of course he
picks up and he backs up what you're
saying that's what he does exactly I
mean we have enough stories between us
that I'm sure we can tell the true ones
all there's no there's no inflating any
of these so let me let me let me just
ask you this before I let you go what do
you think of the rule fourth and 15 that
you you'd be able to go for it once and
maintain possession of the ball or from
your perspective as a defensive minded
coach having to defend such a thing -
maybe lock a game up what do you think
yeah I'm against it which I think part
of the reason is you know there's if you
get pass interference automatic first
down
there's a lot of a lot of things that
could happen there that you know and I'm
a traditionalist anyway I like football
the way it is so most part but in my
that that's just my opinion of how it is
but if they pass it and that's how we
have to defend it them and we'll go
about our business and we'll work like
crazy to get stopped
but even
you know you do the you do the math
right now it's about ten and a half
percent chance 11 percent chance of you
getting an onside kick a much better
chance for say Kirk Cousins to go you
know find Thielen or Kyle Rudolph as he
did in the endzone and in New Orleans
you know what it would benefit you to
would you say you know we've worked so
hard to get to a the league is so tough
you work so hard to get to to a
situation where they have to kick an
onside kick well your defense gets a
little bit of a rest and then you got a
you know but they score let's say they
score and obviously our job is not let
them score but if they do score then the
beat the defense has to go out there
again and try and get him stopped it
could have been a 10-play Drive or
whatever it was but you know I just feel
like you know maybe they should they
should change the onside kick rule
somehow or something like that but it
just it's just weird to me okay fourth
and 15 let's let's have one more play
okay so that's the way it is sure well
are they and I guess to bring this
conversation completely full circle it
seems like many many moons ago the free
agency or the new league ear I'll ask
you the question if you don't mind that
I get asked a lot what happened with
Stefon Diggs what did what a Diggs have
to go from Minnesota well honestly Diggs
did not have to go we we really didn't
have any intention of trading him you
know quite honestly he you know we put
out a couple tweets and you know there's
some things going on there but you know
so far works extremely hard
he's practices like crazy he wants the
ball like all receivers do and really
what happened was Buffalo came in and
gave us you know all those ticks and and
so in word you know we were up against
it from a salary cap and so we just felt
like we could save some money get a
bunch of pics maybe getting you know a
young receiver like yeah JJ they've got
so you know I wish him well he's a good
kid he worked hard for me he was he was
you know really if you said somebody was
a pain
but I wouldn't say him so way worse guys
to him I think he's you know I hope he
has a great career finishes up strong
Mike Zimmer really appreciate the time
you stay safe in Kentucky and I look
forward to the time where you can get
back in your facility with your team and
play some football I look forward to
that
Thank You Mitch stay healthy thanks for
all you got a thank you that's Mike
Zimmer that head coach the Minnesota
Vikings hey you watched all the way to
the end thanks for that watch more right
here